The Long Island Horticultural Research
and Extension Center is a campus of
Cornell University. We've been here in
Riverhead, New York for 98 years and our
purpose here is to help the agricultural
industry
succeed. There is a lot of need for
up-to-date research and assistance with
growing plants. The impatiens is
primarily of interest to the greenhouse
growers on Long Island as well as some
of the nurseries -- the commercial, the
retail establishments that sell plants.
Right here we've been breeding impatiens
plants trying to develop
resistance to the disease called
impatiens downy mildew. And there's
always problems when you do breeding and
one of the one of the issues that we
found out with this plant is they have
what we call explosive seed pods so that
means when the seed pods are ripe they explode.
And of course if you're trying to
harvest seed that's a problem because
then they're all over the greenhouse
floor. So we use we use a technique
called plant tissue culture to assist
our breeding program and essentially
plant tissue culture is a way to grow
plants in a sterile environment on a
nutrient medium under controlled
environment. So we will remove the pods
that we've pollinated on these plants
about 14 to 16 days after we've
pollinated them and we take those pods
to our laboratory they're sterilized on
the outside and then they're opened
aseptic ly to expose the seeds and those
seeds that are placed in tissue culture
to germinate. The nice thing about that
process is that once they germinate
in tissue culture they're always going
to be there as a stock plant for us.
They're always going be available. We can
take cuttings of those plants and bring
them back here to the greenhouse. If we
find out that we have a successful plant,
a successful hybrid, we have the mother
plant in tissue culture free of diseases
free of insects and we can then rapidly
propagate that plant to increase the
numbers quickly.
And these are the results of some of
that breeding research. So all these
plants that you see here are resistant
to the disease. We've done field trials
for them for the last two years but our
next step then is to produce a plant
that has a nice looking flower and a
nice symmetrical growth habit so we are
continuing to hybridize these plants and
will continue to develop it until we
get a nice seed propagated plant.